لذلك ، يحتوي هذا على الكثير من
القطع المتقزحة التي
سقطت ، سألتقطها ولكن
سيكون من الصعب إعادتها
بعد شهر من انفجار ميناء بيروت العام الماضي
كلير كويا بير
الذي كان عبارة عن حقيبة عرض تحتوي على 74
نادرًا  قطع من
الأواني الزجاجية الرومانية القديمة والعصور الوسطى
في المتحف الأثري
للجامعة الأمريكية في بيروت في البداية
شعرت
بالرعب
وكان الأمر مخيفًا حقًا مثل مقدار ما
كان علينا إنجازه ، وعاد كلير ترميم من
المعهد الوطني الفرنسي
للتراث الثقافي مرة أخرى
بيروت للمساعدة في
إنهاء المهمة وكيف يمكن مقارنة ذلك
مع أحجية الصور المقطوعة ، إنه من الصعب جدًا
ألا يكون لديك عادة
72 لغزًا من الألغاز مختلطة معًا بشكل
صحيح ومن ثم لديك صعوبة إضافية
تتمثل في هشاشة الكائن  إن تركيب
آلاف القطع الصغيرة المسننة من
الزجاج المكسور معًا مرة أخرى هي مهمة
تتطلب دقة شاقة
وصبر العمل تدرس ماريا
علم الآثار
باعتباره يتطلب  يصعب
إصلاح هذه الأواني الزجاجية القديمة لأنها تقول إنه سيكون من الأسهل إصلاح
هذه الأواني الزجاجية القديمة
بدلاً من إصلاح لبنان بلد تمزق
مرارًا وتكرارًا في السنوات
الأخيرة بسبب الأزمات والكوارث ،
أعتقد أن هذا ممكن أكثر لأن
لديك بالفعل كل القطع على
الصواني
التي لديك للتو  لاختيارهم ولكن
بالنسبة لـ 11 قطعة تعرف
أنك لا تملكهم حقًا ،
فسيتعين عليك العثور عليهم أو
إذا لم تجدهم ، فسيتعين علينا إنشاءها
بأنفسنا
ولكن هذا الجهد لاستعادة  جزء صغير
من تراث لبنان الغني
هو العلاج في حد ذاته ، كما تقول أمينة المتحف
نادين بانايوت عندما تكون على الأرض
تلتقط تلك القطع من
خلال الزجاج
وأنت وأنت سعيد جدًا عندما تحدد
بعض القطع وتضعها معًا.
كان له تأثير علاجي بالفعل
يوضح هذا المشروع أنه حتى
الأشياء الممزقة إلى مئات
القطع
الصغيرة ليست قابلة للإصلاح. بن ويدمان سي إن إن
بيروت